un vaccin pour assurer le maintien de la
paix en république centrafricaine le
contexte politique est tendu alors que
le pays est dirigé depuis décembre
dernier par faustin archange touadéra il
reste toujours sous la menace de groupes
armés pour maintenir la stabilité le
conseil de sécurité de l'onu maintient
des troupes dans le pays depuis 2014 et
pour protéger les autres il faut d'abord
se protéger soi-même contre un
adversaire insensible aux balles
le coc vie 19 la force est ici pour
comment accomplir son mandat il on doit
se protéger et la protection que nous
avons à ce moment c'est la vaccine et
moi comme la chaîne de commande
je donne l'exemple avec vinny une
revenant ici pour montrer à tous ceux
que la bassine la unique forme que nous
avons de protection c'est très important
pour nous car nous ne pouvons pas
continuer à sauver des gens si nous ne
sommes pas en sécurité
soto préserver c'est mieux pour tout le
monde je pense que nous serons mieux
placé pour protéger des autres lorsque
nous serons en bonne santé et je veux
encourager tout le personnel
international à apaiser ces craintes et
à se manifester pour se faire vacciner
une initiative davantage à titre de
précaution que d'urgence la centrafrique
n'aurait pour l'instant enregistré que
75 décès pour 5700 cas depuis le début
de la pandémie
cependant ces données sont partiels car
les populations de grandes parties du
pays n'ont pas accès aux services de
santé
par ailleurs selon les statistiques de
l'université américaine john hopkins
le virus se propage un peu plus depuis
quelques semaines
le pays a ainsi enregistré pas moins de
700 nouveaux cas durant les 30 derniers
jours soit une augmentation de 14% une
menace grandissante que les nations
unies ne peuvent pas prendre à la légère